okay so our last speaker of the day is
matt jacobs and he's going to talk about
extending the details
uh great thank you so much and uh thank
you to uh simone and katie for uh
inviting me to talk here um it's really
been awesome being at the simons
institute um
for the last two months and also the
next few months i guess um so this is a
joint work with um a bunch of people who
uh
at some point were at ucla some of them
are also still there um
and yeah this is just going to be a
collection of a couple different things
um
and
what i really want to talk about is okay
um
can we use the jko scheme to evolve some
equations that are really not vascular
stein to uh gradient flows um and i'm
going to focus on uh just one particular
model today
uh but in fact there's actually a lot of
different places where you can do this
um
okay so
uh the model that i'm gonna look at are
these kind of tumor growth models
so here a row is modeling the density of
some
tumor
right so we look at all the cells we
sort of just average them and zoom out
and that's our density
and then the other thing is right these
these cells are growing they don't
really like touching each other and they
sort of push each other around and that
induces a pressure
um and so basically you should just
think that uh this pressure is like some
increasing function of the density
um and it's going to
uh push
push the cells okay and so that's
basically uh this first part of the
equation over here
um but of course right these these are
tumor cells they should be growing
um
and uh so on this other side we have
this growth term which is going to be a
decreasing function of the pressure
and the idea is right uh these cells
don't like competing for space and so if
they're in some region where there isn't
a lot of space left they're going to
grow really slowly
but if you know they're in a region
where there's lots of space then they
can grow faster okay and that's
essentially what's uh sort of going on
in this picture here so i have some
tumor cell basic or collection of tumor
cells and at the center we have really
high pressure so there it's growing
really slowly
but along the edges it can be uh growing
faster
um and okay clearly right
uh if i didn't have this source term
then i would have a very nice w2
gradient flow
but it's there and it's very important
um so
it's certainly not a w-2
gradient flow
um
so the uh most uh common choice for this
coupling between the pressure and the
density is just some uh power function
um but the case which uh
is sort of most mathematically
interesting um and also actually very
physically relevant as well is when you
send this power off to infinity
um and essentially once you do that
you're sort of just adding
incompressibility to the system you're
saying that uh the density row can never
go
above one
and when you do that you can actually
understand the pressure as a lagrange
multiplier for this incompressibility
um and now you don't have this uh direct
connection between the pressure and the
density so if i know the density that
doesn't mean that i know the pressure
but uh nonetheless they're still going
to satisfy this relation
which really sort of it's just like a
lagrange multiplier
condition
um and so what you end up getting is you
get a free boundary problem that has
this sharp interface between um
essentially these cancerous regions and
non-cancerous regions
so rho will actually basically always be
either zero or
uh one um and so uh it's it's
numerically difficult to solve these uh
free boundary problems um
and uh you know something like the jko
scheme
is really nice because uh anytime you
have something variational and implicit
uh you feel less scared of trying to
handle these kinds of equations
um
i should mention uh this this model was
first introduced by uh this really
really nice paper by uh for tom quiros
and vasquez
they they were really the first ones to
analyze uh this incompressible
uh limit
okay so um
let me just say
uh one more scary thing about uh these
equations um which is sometimes really
bad things happen and when do really bad
things happen they happen when uh the
the density undergoes a topological
change okay so
basically you can imagine that you start
out with uh the density
where it's living on some annulus okay
and so uh i have room to sort of dump
mass outside but i also have room to
dump mass inside okay so uh
in the outer ring the pressure is
pushing outwards but in this inner ring
it's pushing inwards because there's i
can place mass there
but what's going to happen is right it's
gonna grow and eventually i'm going to
completely fill this hole
um
and right at the moment where that
happens all of a sudden there's no room
left in the center
and so what that means is actually all
of the pressure needs to start pushing
stuff out okay so at least the gradient
is going to undergo this very
discontinuous change
where it was first pushing stuff towards
the center
and then all of a sudden it has to be
pushing stuff out
and actually it's going to be pushing
stuff out right
um
sort of that's actually now where
there's the least amount of room to put
stuff
um and if you look at sort of just a
cross section basically any radial cross
section uh this is what's going to
happen so you sort of have these two
humps they're going to get closer and
closer together and then at some point
they're going to merge um these these
should be uh symmetric but
um i can't draw it any better than that
um
so uh basically what's gonna happen is
right at the moment
where this hole gets filled uh you have
this really bad time discontinuity in
the pressure um
and uh you know this this just is a
feature of this equation that also makes
it um hard to solve
um okay so that was a scary thing there
is at least one good thing which is uh
the equation satisfies a comparison
principle okay so
if i start off with uh
you know two different tumors
um i'm sort of considering them
separately but let's just say that i
know that one of them started out inside
of the other then actually will always
stay inside um as these two things
evolve
um and this is not actually completely
obvious
because this smaller tumor
has a lower pressure
which means it should be able to grow
faster
and so you might get scared that maybe
right at this point where they're
touching the smaller one can actually
grow faster and escape
um but it turns out it can't okay so
um there really is a comparison
principle
for this problem
and if you can
design a numerical scheme that respects
this comparison principle then that
gives you a really powerful stability
and you know you can feel somewhat safe
that you're actually doing a good job of
solving this pde
okay so
that is essentially the goal so we want
to try to design a numerical method
to simulate this model you know that
satisfies these nice properties so
ideally we'd like something that's
unconditionally stable independent of
the time step
we want to preserve this comparison
principle
uh that this equation has then we don't
have to worry so so much about some of
the really bad behavior
um and of course we would like to know
that it converges to the continuum pd
um as we send whatever discretization we
have to zero
um and right it's very tempting to use a
jko type scheme okay so when you have a
w2 gradient flow you solve it with a jko
scheme
it's unconditionally stable
and it typically inherits
all of the nice properties that the
continuum pde has so if your continuum
pde has a comparison principle then
usually your jko scheme also has a
comparison principle and so on right so
we would really like to use something
like that
um
but at least we can't use it right out
of the box because we have a problem
where mass is changing
okay
so um let me just talk about uh some
previous works
that have looked at this problem
and uh of course this is not at all
exhaustive
um
and so the first one is this very nice
paper by uh shizat and simone
um where what they did is uh they tried
to view this equation as a gradient flow
um
in the hellinger kanterovich distance
which is kind of the first thing that
you would want to do you say okay i have
this equation where mass changes
so let me just replace optimal transport
with a notion of optimal transport that
allows for
changing mass
and the problem is
that
uh
when you do that the energy and this
growth term have to be very closely
coupled okay so you can't actually
choose them to be
completely independent
but of course when you can
you get a very very very nice way of
solving this equation
um
the other thing you might think of doing
right is just to do a splitting scheme
so you can say let me just uh evolve
this part of the equation
with a jko scheme and then i'll just do
another step
where i handle this mass changing term
and the problem is that this scheme gets
into a lot of trouble when you consider
this incompressible case
and it's because in this incompressible
case you cannot directly relate the
pressure and the density to each other
and so if you try to separate this part
from that part you're going to run into
a lot of trouble
okay
so before i um
tell you guys what we did
uh let me just say one more thing about
uh why
this is probably not a gradient flow
so of course there's some possibility
right that there's some really really
crazy metric
that uh
you know you can actually understand
this equation as a gradient flow in that
metric
but
this inequality um
is sort of what convinces me that no
that's really not the case so what is
this all we did was we took the equation
we integrated against the pressure
um and if you do this for
uh
you know just a w-2 gradient flow you
get the energy dissipation inequality so
usually you don't have this term here
and it's just saying right that uh
basically all of the kinetic energy you
spend is getting used to reduce the
energy
um but that's not happening here because
we're adding mass to the problem um and
so this second term here is kind of
accounting for uh how much you're kind
of increasing the energy again
when you continue to add
the mass
um and so this energy is really not
being dissipated okay so for sure it's
not a gradient flow with respect to this
energy
and it seems very unlikely that you can
find some other kind of modified energy
uh where you can actually understand
this
thing as a dissipation inequality at
least for uh completely general choices
of uh g
okay
so
we have something that's not probably
not a gradient flow that's fine
sometimes life just doesn't give us
gradient flows
but it turns out that you can still
use the jko scheme
by making a very very very simple
modification
um and this is what we did
so
this is our scheme for evolving the
equation
and
what do you do
you try to minimize the energy
and then you're going to have this extra
term here
and this is sort of a term that's going
to encourage growth
and then
we have this w2 term
and so you see that actually i'm not
plugging in the density from the
previous iteration
i'm plugging in the density and then i'm
also allowing for some growth to happen
so again this alpha is supposed to
represent the growth rate
and by putting that in there it sort of
gets us around the problem
that uh w2 isn't defined between two
densities of different mass
so
what we're doing right is we're just
saying okay that's fine
let me just change the mass right here
and then uh the row that i choose at the
next time step
will still have that same
uh mass
um and let me just say you really cannot
interpret
this whole thing as a distance anymore
okay so
if i didn't have this energy term here
and the only thing i had were those
second two terms
then i have this term that encourages
growth
so
i grow because that's going to decrease
the value of this functional
but if this thing's not here then i
could just choose row to be exactly this
and so i pay no transportation cost okay
so
in this model
you are not paying for adding mass okay
so adding or even subtracting mass
um
is not something that's really showing
up in
a metric
in the same way that you would think
about that as in like the hellinger
kanterovich distance
okay so the only reason
that transportation is actually going to
happen
is because i have this energy the energy
does not like
mass buildup and so if i grow
then i still want to do something to
sort of push
density
away
okay so
what we need to do now is we need to
figure out f okay so
the question is uh if i want any g
is there some f
that makes this work and ideally i would
like f to be convex because i want to
solve the convex variational problem
okay and so to do that um i'm going to
analyze the dual problem
so essentially whenever i think about
optimal transport
i always think about it from the uh
kanterovich dual perspective
so
um i want to introduce that problem and
then basically all of the analysis all
the numerics that we're going to do are
going to be based on this dual problem
um
so let me just introduce some notation
that i'm going to uh use
so
um
here we have the c transform and the
conjugate c transform which are
basically inverses to one another uh
this is the convention that's most
convenient uh for this problem
and uh i'm going to suppress the
notation on this time step tau
uh but it's there okay
um
and then this is the notation that i'm
going to use for the induced transport
maps so when i actually look at the
argument and r max
of these c transforms i get these maps
which uh if we're at the optimal
pressure are going to be the optimal
transport maps
um and then we'll also use this uh c
transform variation formula
and if i was doing it with the conjugate
c transform instead then i would just
get the conjugate map okay
so
uh to
get to the dual formulation we're just
going to use uh canary duality to write
w2
there should be a soup here so it's a
soup over this function p
[Music]
and once we do that we transform the
primal problem into this mini max
problem
and um i've already i've just rearranged
the terms in a slightly more suggestive
way because if you look at this guy here
it essentially looks like a legendre
transform
and indeed if we fix the pressure
we interchange and we minimize with
respect to rho then we are going to get
uh e star which is or minus e star uh
right the legendre transform
of e and one thing i want to point out
is uh when you do this legendre
transform you're actually minimizing
over
densities
and what that is going to mean is all of
these slopes of e star have to actually
be non-negative so e star
is both convex and increasing
and that will be important in a second
so
now
um it's much easier to understand
this problem uh what f
alpha
is doing right because now i just have f
alpha and i have something linear in
alpha
okay so we're going to play the same
game we're going to fix p
we're going to interchange we're going
to minimize over alpha
and um this is the equation you get
and you see that alpha
is equal to f star prime
of negative pc
okay so
um
i want alpha to be the growth rate so i
really want alpha to be equal to g of p
and so uh this is the choice that i want
to make
okay so this g was supposed to be a
decreasing function of the pressure
and that's great because here i have f
star prime
of minus a right f star prime if it's
the derivative of convex function should
be increasing but i have the minus so
this thing is decreasing
um
and so it means that yes i can choose a
convex f
that will allow me to achieve
uh this desired growth rate g
okay
um
so now that we've done this we can plug
in this choice of alpha
and
finally uh we get this dual problem um
and so it turns out that if you play
around with uh
the uh various terms that you got when
you plugged in alpha what you actually
end up getting is this anti-derivative
of g
and so
this is your dual problem here
so
this almost
looks like
the
dual problem that you get
if you just try to look at the dual
problem to the jko scheme
the thing that is different
is this g term
but the good thing is that this uh g bar
is a concave function okay so this is
basically a uh
concave maximization
problem
okay
um and uh let me just point out that in
this case where the energy is given by
this power function uh this is exactly
what the dual problem is going to look
like
and so if you want to think about this
uh incompressible case where we send
gamma to infinity
then this e star of p is exactly max p
comma zero
and so one thing that's worth pointing
out is actually as soon as you look at a
value of gamma that's larger than two
this uh dual energy term is not going to
be smooth
um
and it turns out that this causes a
little bit of an issue but you can get
around that
and even in the most singular case where
you send
gamma to infinity and you really get
a complete kink
okay
so um
the uh other thing i want to say is
there's actually a second way to write
down this dual problem
um and this is because right i can keep
playing around with c transforms so if i
take the c transform twice
i have to get something smaller if i
take it uh three times then i end up
back where i started
and so if you plug
the c transform of some candidate
function uh into this thing you actually
will always increase the value
um
and so that tells you that any maximizer
actually has to be a c concave function
oh and let me just point out this is
where the fact that e star is monotone
is important
okay so uh
p c c bar is smaller than p
and uh that means that this term
is subtracting off less than this term
and so that's good
um
and so since i know that any maximizer
has to be c concave
i can also
think about this
in the conjugate space so i can also
introduce this variable q
that is the c transform of p
and i can also think about the problem
in this way and it's completely
equivalent
um
and this will be relevant when i start
talking about uh the numerics because
we're actually going to optimize both of
these problems simultaneously
okay
um so
uh let me just talk about the optimality
conditions for the dual problem because
that's what will allow us to see that
we're uh really solving this uh pde that
we care about
and so
if you solve the dual problem you have
to satisfy this euler lagrange equation
and this map is showing up
uh
precisely because we took a variation
through the c transform
um
and that's going to induce a push
forward of this measure
okay so this is what the optimal dual
potential needs to satisfy and what you
can do is you can then check well
all of these interchanges that we did
were they really justified do i really
have strong duality here
and uh the answer is yes so if you
actually just construct a primal
solution row using this formula and
alpha using this formula
then it turns out you can just check
that the value of the dual function
at p n plus 1 is equal to the value of
the primal function at these uh two
minimizers that you've constructed and
so in fact these have to be the primal
solutions
uh so this really is rho n plus one
um and so strong duality holds you can
just use the dual problem to think about
everything
okay
so
putting everything together
uh this is what we get
so we get this duality relation between
the pressure and the density we needed
to have that
um
to be really precise i should be saying
that uh these are in each other's
subdifferentials especially in the case
where we don't have smoothness but
whatever let me just write it like this
um and then we have uh
this push forward equation and in fact
this is actually basically a weak
encoding of that continuity equation pde
with a source term okay so if i look at
this discrete time derivative
i use the fact that i can write
this term as a push forward of row n
plus one
what i see is that this term is exactly
equal to this guy okay so here is my
source term showing up so i'm getting dt
rho times some test function
i'm getting the source term on the other
side and then this guy is actually a
weak encoding
of
the divergence term
um so
this inverse map is exactly
x plus tau gradient p n plus 1 of x
and so
this difference is essentially the dot
product of the
gradient of the test function with pn
plus 1.
this is how much error you're making
right it's the next term in the taylor
expansion
and so uh as long as you can control
this guy
then
um and you have compactness properties
then you can verify that you're really
solving this equation
um
and i'm not going to say uh too much
more about the compactness and the
convergence because really uh that just
sort of falls into
a lot of the stuff that's already very
well known
about gradient flows
especially the convergence of these two
non-linear terms actually the
convergence of this term
is a little bit more interesting and
there's some cases where it's very hard
but whatever
just believe me this scheme does
converge to the uh pde
okay the thing that's a little bit more
interesting is
actually verifying that this has a
comparison principle
um
and so
what this is just saying is if i feed
two ordered densities into this scheme
and i look at what pops out then if the
densities were ordered then the
solutions also are ordered right that's
exactly what
um
the the comparison principle is saying
and of course if i keep iterating the
scheme that i have this comparison
principle forever
and again we're actually going to
prove this using the dual problem so in
fact it's enough to show that the
optimal pressures
are ordered because they're coupled to
the optimal densities
through the derivative of a convex
function right that's monotone
so i just need to show the pressures are
ordered
and
um
it turns out that all you need is this
very
uh trivial observation
so
um
recall that these maps t sub p are
supposed to be the arguments
of when you take the c transform
and what i'm doing is i just want to
look at the set
where
p zero
is smaller than p1 okay so these are
just two seconds k functions i'm looking
where p0 uh sorry is larger than p1
and the point is if p0
decides to choose a point in this set u
then p1 has to also decide to choose a
point in this set u
and uh we'll we'll also know that the c
transforms are ordered so the ordering
of the c transforms is actually very
easy because here i can just choose
the minimizer that was chosen for p0 i
know that's in u
p 1 is smaller than p 0 and u
and so of course this has to be smaller
to see
why t p1 has to be in u
if this guy is in u i mean basically
what it's saying right is uh
p0 chose a point inside of u
if i was choosing something different
for p1 either i have to spend
more
uh in my transportation cost
to go somewhere else
but that wouldn't really make any sense
because then i could have done the same
thing with p0
and if i go outside with p1
then i could do a better job by choosing
that same outside point with p0
um
okay and so this is the only way in
which optimal transport is going to show
up in this comparison theorem argument
um and so what's really interesting is
we don't use anything about the
quadratic cost
so in fact uh this observation
is true
as long as you have some cost that
induces
uh maps right so as long as you know
that you have a cost where maps exist
you have this lemma and this is the only
place we where we're going to use uh
optimal transport in the sense that it's
the only place where the c transform
will be relevant
okay
so now that we know this um basically
the comparison argument is just this
sort of
two-liner okay so
i have you i look
at the characteristic function of that
set
and then i just integrate my optimality
condition against chi
and this is what i get right so i have
chi against this guy it has to be equal
to the integral of chi against the push
forward which means i can just write
that as chi composed with this map
okay
and
all of the inequalities here are
straightforward except when i go from
this first line to this second line
that's where we're going to use that
lemma okay so
here
i'm on chi that's where p0 is bigger
this is a monotone function and so of
course
e star at p1 is smaller
then i use the optimality condition
and now i want to use the lemma okay so
if
this guy is equal to one that means that
t of p zero sent mass into u
and so that means that p1 must also do
it as well and so
if this guy is non-zero this guy is
non-zero um
and similarly i know that on that set
this guy is smaller
than this guy
but g is a decreasing function okay so
um
basically the llama tells us that we can
go from this line to that line
and then this last thing i'm just using
the fact that i know
that row one is bigger than row zero
that's this inequality and then i get
back to what i started with just using
the optimality condition for p0
okay and so we see that all of these
inequalities have to actually be
equalities
and so if e star is a strictly convex
function
or if g
is strictly decreasing
that will only be possible
if u has measure zero
and if they're not strictly
um convex or strictly
decreasing well you just approximate
them with something that is and then the
argument goes through
okay so
um
that is essentially everything i wanted
to say
about the more analytic aspects
um
i don't have that much time left but let
me just say a little bit about the
numerics
um
so uh the way that
um i'm gonna simulate this problem is by
using the back and forth method uh to uh
solve the dual problem so uh the back
and forth method um i introduced with uh
flavian leger originally for solving um
just optimal transport problems and more
recently
in addition with juan jin li
we extended it to gradient flows
and so now what i'm going to talk about
is using it to do these tumor growth
models
um
and so right we're just going to uh use
this method to do uh h1 gradient ascent
on these two equivalent dual problems
that will give us the optimal pressure
and then you can recover the optimal
density uh through either one of these
two
uh relations that are linking the
pressure and the density so this
relation always works
this one
things are potentially iffy when this
guy is not smooth
but actually in the incompressible case
you can recover the density from the
pressure even though you can't recover
the pressure from the density
and in general you prefer to recover the
optimal density uh this way because you
know that this guy is a c conv concave
function it has good regularity
properties
whereas computing this push forward is
kind of a pain
so this is what the algorithm looks like
you alternate gradient ascent
on
one of these problems you take a c
transform to switch to the other problem
you do gradient ascent there and then
you switch back with the conjugate um
c transform
and we're doing all of these gradient
updates in h1
and an h1 gradient is just equivalent to
preconditioning l2
by this
poisson equation essentially
and you can at least if you're on a grid
uh you can solve that very efficiently
uh with fft
okay so why are we doing these things um
h1 is the weakest inner product where
these two functions i and j
have a hope of actually being smooth
okay so if i try to do gradient descent
in some uh weaker norm it's going to be
horribly uh unstable and this is
precisely because of the c transform
term
um
the hessians of these functions are
really complicated so they're not even
guaranteed to be l smooth in h1 but
again this is the weakest possible space
where that could possibly be true
um and actually another really nice
thing about working in h1 is these
non-smooth functions or things that
we're used to thinking of as being
non-smooth functions
are actually
smooth in h1
um as long as uh
the boundary of these sets where the
singularity happens is not too crazy
okay and so it's basically
the hessian
of that function is sort of going to be
a singular measure that concentrates on
the boundary
okay of course you can't bound
integration on a singular measure
uh in terms of l2 but h1 functions you
can actually integrate them on this
boundary okay so these functions even
though we're used to thinking them
thinking of them
as uh not being smooth
they kind of are smooth uh in h1
and
right the reason you actually want to
alternate between these two functions
is because their hessians are sort of
inverse to one another and so it means
that
you can sort of always
step in directions
where your hessians
have larger eigenvalues right so where
the eigenvalues of the hessian of one
function are small they're big on the
other function and so this gives you a
way to sort of
keep
moving um
and uh
at least on grids uh you can you can
compute these uh c tran c transforms
um very quickly
okay so um
i'm basically out of time
but uh let me just show you guys a few
fun videos
and then i will stop so um these are all
just going to be of the incompressible
case
and so uh all these different shapes are
going to grow and they're going to merge
we get topological changes and it's fine
and you can see that uh the scheme is
maintaining the sharp interface the
whole time
here's the same example but with a
growth function that's more heavily
penalized by the pressure
and it sort of just grows more slowly
in both cases
you see that at the end the things start
to become ball like
and so it seems that sort of this uh
ball that keeps growing is an attracting
solution uh for
everything um and let me just say one
thing we're
looking at doing in the future is this
same problem but with two cell
populations and uh here things get much
more complicated you don't actually have
a comparison principle
you have to worry about two different
interfaces
but nonetheless things at least
seem to work
uh reasonably well and here's just one
more video of that case
and so let me stop there i apologize uh
for going over
any questions
yeah thank you very much for the nice
talk
so you might already mentioned this but
why can't you use the helen jacondorwich
uh distance in the scheme in jk scheme
uh so
basically and simone correct me if i'm
wrong
but if you do that
uh
then you can get pdes that look like
this
and so you see that these two terms have
to be related to each other
um
yeah well
so what i mean is that when you when you
consider when you add
the additional potential okay because
what you're doing so you consider an
additional potential
and you consider this term as an
external potential right because then
you freeze it because you you treat it
as a as an explicit in in in the scheme
but then also what you do you consider
the distance
versus a distance between like rho and
so these other like rho and one plus two
alpha and then also what i'm saying can
you can't you use their arrangement
contour which so you add the additional
potential
would it make sense
so let me just see
because when you want so you see when
you add the additional
right so then you you need to pay a
price
in terms of the mass right and then so
the question would be would it make
sense to consider
helen g kantorovich yeah i mean i i
think you certainly could um
but uh
i don't know if um doing something like
that necessarily allows you to access a
larger class of equations maybe it does
okay um yeah that was yeah it was a
great idea yeah thank you yeah
any other questions
okay how can i read it
and use themselves
oh yeah yeah whoever asked the question
yourself and ask questions
okay
oh sorry he can't amuse himself he has a
very good reason his daughter is
sleeping
in the audience can uh sympathize with
that so yeah can you type it to me uh i
hope
yeah
is there any other questions from the
audience
why so pressure depend on the density
um
so you you can take
a right you can take any
essentially
[Music]
any convex function e but for it to
really be physically meaningful you
probably also want e to be uh increasing
as well
so i just wonder that for for your
simulation because you know they have
this connection to the free boundary
problem so um can you really
really that's when this power wall goes
infinity
yeah because right when um
that case is
so when these go to infinity in the dual
problem you just get max of p comma zero
um and so you you've traded a constraint
for something that's not smooth
um
but uh right so
when you take
uh variations of this thing you generate
these singular measures
but because you do the um
the update steps in h1
that's that's fine
essentially
okay i have a
leonard's question he says thanks matt
for the nice talk can you relate this to
the relatively unknown paper of kinder
lair and walkington approximation of
parabolic equations using the vostein
metric from 99. it looks like you're
taking it
it looks like you're taking a non-linear
version of their analysis where they
consider mass variations given by a
simpler source term not depending on row
or row or p
all right
i don't know the speaker
okay so any other questions
not listening to that again